vid 19 on the rise many valley
businesses continue to be impacted
especially latino businesses who say
they need assistance
to keep up with all the changes a news
now reporter sally jeremiah spoke to one
group
fighting to keep the little guys open
very important still up in
24 hours if i if i can but right now i
can
adolfo ivara is the owner of the don
tortaco franchise located near martin
luther king and craig
he says the pandemic has brought a lot
of change to his business
we are so scared about that and we go
down the business in the
first couple weeks through the many don
tortaco franchises they tried to share
information with each other to comply
with the new ordinances
a little bit hard to know everything
about it we don't have maybe
very much time you know to learn about
computers or something like that we are
you know just we just know how to work
that's why the latin chamber of commerce
and the legal aid center of southern
nevada says
their goal is to provide all the
resources needed in order for small
businesses to thrive
to help a small business have access to
capital
which we've had multiple conversations
with all of our senators our congress
people
sba banks and we continue to have those
kind of conversations
peter guzman of the nevada chamber of
commerce wants to provide businesses
with masks and information on how to get
tested
but it doesn't stop there legal advice
is now available
if they are small and they have fewer
than 25 employees and they
have experienced a reduction
in their income of more than
25 percent since march 12
to now then they're eligible for our
services sally jaramillo 8 news now
the legal aid center of southern nevada
has already connected a handful of small
business owners with lawyers in the
community who offer free assistance
to see if you qualify submit an
application they will review it